This episode is brought to you by Ridge wallet.
Hey wisecrack, Jared here. Hollywood's a tricky business.
Audience's tastes constantly shift over time.
As genre that's popular in one moment can run out of fashion a second later,
but there's one thing you can always count on. People love to be scared.
That's why no matter the decade,
horror films have been a constant fixture in cinema from the universal monsters
of the thirties, to the slashers of the eighties and nineties,
to the so-called torture porn of the early aughts horror today,
though isn't necessarily categorized by mass killers or monsters.
Instead it's become mostly synonymous with one company Blumhouse.
Since 2007,
Blumhouse has revitalized the genre with hit after hit like paranormal activity,
the purge get out us and many more.
Their films have pushed horror into uncharted territory.
Gaining both commercial and critical success held many have even labeled this
current period.
The golden age of horror on the surface Blumhouse has films all appear to be
different. Running the gamut from ghost stories to slashers,
to sociopolitical commentaries.
I would have voted for Obama for a third term. If I could.
Producer and CEO of Blumhouse,
Jason Bluhm even stated that he's always been very conscious of not repeating
himself. He said wearing my entrepreneur's hat.
I'm very conscious of not falling into a pattern.
The tenants of the company are the same,
but the kinds of things that we're doing are very,
very different than 10 years ago.
But the secret sauce of Blumhouse is success might actually be rooted in being
cheapskates. According to Bluhm, the only real pattern is an economic one.
Unlike other studios,
which pour tens or hundreds of millions dollars into a single film,
Blumhouse tries to make sure each film costs no more than 5 billion by being so
budget conscious Blumhouse has strangely enough stumbled into making some of the
most insightful commentaries on a basic part of American life, the home.
So let's find out how in this wisecrack edition on how Blumhouse changed horror
and spoilers ahead for Blumhouse sprites like paranormal activity,
insidious sinister, get out Halloween and us. But before we continue,
I want to give a shout out to this week, sponsored the Ridge wallet.
The Ridge wallet is a light sleek and industrial wallet designed to last you a
lifetime. Each wallet is made with RFID blocking technology,
which protects you from digital pickpockets.
The durable metal also means each wallet comes with a lifetime warranty.
So this could be the last wallet you ever buy. It's perfect.
If you don't want to carry around a bulky old lumpy leather wallet in your
pocket and still want to maximize the amount of cards you carry,
it holds up to 12 cards and still has room for cash.
I got the titanium gunmetal wallet and nothing beats how sleek it is.
The rich team is so confident that you will like it,
that if you don't and send it back within 45 days, you'll receive a full refund.
Grab your own Ridge wallet today by going to
ridge.com/wisecrack and use the promo code wisecrack to get percent off,
you will get free worldwide shipping and returns.
So click the link in the description to get one today.
And now back to the show since Blumhouse needs to keep their costs low,
most of their films are set in a single location and shot in one of the
cheapest, easiest places. A filmmaker can find a house money aside,
most horror films focused on the opposite showing what happens when people leave
their home.
Just look at some of the most popular horror films before Blumhouse arrived on
the scene. In the 1960s,
a young woman left home seeking safety in a creepy motel with great
amenities. In the 1970s,
a group of teens went on a road trip only to face off against this beautiful
family. In the 1980s,
a family leaves home to become caretakers at a hotel only to be haunted by
clear building code violations in the nineties,
some teen vloggers ventured into the woods in search of a witch and things
didn't go much better. And in the early aughts,
a bunch of horny college students went overseas only to end up. Well,
you can probably guess the templates in all these films is the same.
A group of attractive people go on a road trip or camping or overseas,
and typically die in the most horrific fashion possible. The message.
If only everyone could just stay home,
then nothing bad would happen in these films.
Homes are often depicted as safe havens,
a refuge from the horrors of the outside world.
In the midst of terror characters will often remark how they wish they could be
home or talk about what they're going to do when they get back to their real
lives.
Hi,
I just want go home.
Are exceptions to this rule, of course,
but two notable ones are the genres of the haunted house and the home invasion.
A typical haunted house film focuses on, well, of course,
a house in East films,
a group of people will either knowingly or unknowingly move into a haunted
structure. The houses in these films don't represent safety and security.
They are unknown spaces that we know from the start will doom yet another set of
hopeless fools and in the home invasion, horror genre and outside force,
most often a killer threatens the domestic stability of a family stalking
and then attacking them in their home.
The family must then ward off their intruders,
like an unwanted vermin and reestablish the home as a beacon of safety.
These films often end with the killer being literally expelled from the house.
And the closing shot is frequently a wide shot of the house.
The sun coming up in the distance,
showing the horror is over and everything is safe once more. Thus,
ultimately the point of these films is to restore the sanctity of the home.
However, Blumhouse subtly began to shift how horror films,
depict homes in the process, redefining both the haunted house,
the home invasion, genre,
and horror as a whole take their breakout hit 2000 sevens paranormal activity.
Unlike the typical haunted house film focuses on a creepy Gothic and foreboding
home paranormal activities house is well completely ordinary.
There's nothing spooky or creepy about the way it's portrayed. In fact,
the early scenes of the film go out of the way to do the opposite painting,
the most idealistic portrait of the home possible in the opening scene,
Micah films around his house, capturing a shot of his girlfriend,
returning home,
which reveals their lovely suburban neighborhood in these early scenes.
The camera lingers on furniture and decor like we're in an episode of MTV's
Crips and the exact same thing happens in paranormal activity. Two,
the sequel opens with the family,
recording everything in their house for the posterity of their newborn.
Yet again, it's a cribs episode. Come to life.
The camera's showing off the open kitchen, the white sofas, another huge TV.
And let's not forget a jacuzzi,
both paranormal activity films take the time to show just how pristine these
homes are.
They are the quintessential beacons of a safe upper middle-class life.
But of course not everything is as it seems a demonic entity, Hans,
both households though.
The first signs of it are presented as common household disturbances
in the opening scene of paranormal activity.
Katie thinks she hears something strange. Could it be demonic?
Nat Micah dismisses the sound as just ultimately the demonic entity
escalates its attack,
making itself fully known by literally destroying the house in paranormal
activity. The entity cracks Micah and cages photographs,
and in paranormal activity to be entities completely destroyed. The house.
Furniture is damage. My daughter Allie's room master bedroom.
Yeah. So that's great.
Even worse. There's no way to get rid of it. Not even a renowned ghost.
Psychic can help Micah and Katie. He takes one step into the house. And then,
well.
In fact, I've got to get out of here. This thing is very aggravated.
The home simply isn't safe anymore.
I can't, I can't be. I can't just, let's go. Please. Let's call paranormal.
Woody's depiction of the home. Somewhat.
Coincidentally reflects the growing anxiety around housing in the lead up to the
great recession. In 2007,
the housing bubble started to burst as millions of American households with
subprime loans found themselves unable to pay their mortgage. That year alone,
there were over 2.3 million foreclosures. The homes,
people thought were their safe Haven suddenly became their undoing per film
historian James Stone,
the paranormal activity films track the gradual collapse of the economic dream.
The business of the demon is to lay waste to materialist splendor.
Each movie takes place in a sizeable well-appointed home,
and then it all comes crashing down. Stone goes on to cite paranormal activity.
Two specifically in the film, one of the protagonists,
Allie discovers her family's ancestors had made a bargain to become wealthy by
forfeiting the sole of their firstborns.
What if Christie's great-grandmother made a deal with a demon so she could get
rich.
However, because the deal was never fulfilled.
The demons stuck to the family until another son was born thus demon attacks
because their family quite simply hasn't paid their debt as stone rights.
The demon is an agent of the recession because he claims and destroys domestic
space and like even addictive creditor.
The monster begins his campaign of terror.
After a deal is reneged upon Blumhouse.
His later films insidious and sinister go even further showing that it isn't
just a singular home or family that is tainted,
but potentially every household insidious opens much like paranormal activity to
pick thing a seemingly ideal home at the opening credits show.
Something's wrong, right? From the outset,
we see still photographs of a beautiful house,
a family having just moved in yet in many of the shots,
pictures and chairs move on their own. Sure enough.
It's not long before the family realizes they're in a haunted house.
I'm scared of this house. There's something wrong with this place.
I'm not imagining it. I can feel it. It's. It's like a sickness.
Prospect of being paranormally terrorized.
The family does the only sensible thing they move. However,
despite moving to a new home, nothing changes,
they begin to experience the same ghostly hauntings. Yet again,
it turns out that the family's comatose son is a beacon for the supernatural
world, inviting the ghosts into the physical realm. Thus,
no matter where they go, no home will ever be safe.
Their house will always be haunted. The same is true in sinister.
After a true crime novelist Ellison Oswald discovers his new home may be haunted
by a demonic entity. He yet again,
does the seemingly sensible thing getting the hell out yet,
as it turns out the entity haunting the house,
but Google is a demonic parasite that travels from home to home.
Mr. Oswald, you just moved out of the last house in line.
If this guy is still out there, you not only just sped up his timeline,
you put yourself in it.
Only after a family moves,
that beagle is able to possess the youngest to kill the rest of the family.
Thus by moving Ellison has inadvertently placed himself and his family in mortal
danger,
both insidious and sinister reject the notion of a singular haunted house in the
traditional haunted house film. As long as you escape the house, you're safe.
However, in both insidious and sinister, the haunting follows the family.
Fleeing does nothing to solve the problem.
And in fact may spell your doom and it's not just the home,
but the entire neighborhood.
That's no longer safe in the early 1980s and amid public concerns around crime
rates. A new form of living began to sprout up across the country,
the gated community in ed Blakely and Mary Gail Snyder's fortress America.
They detailed how Americans were increasingly choosing to move to these
supposedly safer communities.
As they write Americans of all classes are fording up attempting to secure the
value of their houses,
reduce or escape from the impact of crime and find neighbors who share their
sense of the good life in the purge.
The logic of the gated community is made extreme.
It's no longer one secured neighborhood that keeps one safe from outsiders,
but an individual's house turned fortress. The Sandins live in an ideal, bright,
suburban neighborhood where everyone knows your it's the type of place where
your neighbors even bake you homemade cookies.
The Sandins have a deluxe security system that is supposedly foolproof in
protecting them from the violence of the outside world.
As such the family believes they are completely safe on purpose.
I know bad things do happen tonight, but we can afford protection.
So we'll be fine. Just like always no worries. Okay.
However,
the Sandins are so focused on protecting themselves from the outside world.
They failed to realize the actual threat is within their own community.
It's not some other it's their neighbors.
The same that gave them the delightful treats, the gated community of the purge.
Isn't the safe Haven from the outside world.
It's the nexus from which violence originates. Similarly, get out in virtue.
The idea of these safe suburbs by opening with a black man, a quote unquote,
outsider lost and scared amongst the white middle-class affluence.
Creepy, confusing, suburban
girls serious though, like a sore thumb.
And sure enough, his paranoia approves, right?
When he's quickly abducted in the middle of all the perfectly cut grass,
matching driveways and brightly lit homes get out.
It does away with the very pretense of safety in the suburbs. Instead,
the suburban home is something to escape to get out from when Chris arrives at
his girlfriend's family home, he immediately notices something is wrong.
It may seem like the typical suburban ideal, but underneath something is amiss.
Chris sees that the only black people in the house are servants and that they're
acting off later when there's a party at the house,
he realizes that nearly everyone there is white and staring at him.
Like they haven't met a black person that doesn't work.
Of course it turns out Chris's girlfriend is part of a weird brain transplanting
Colt,
and that Christine's do kill each member of the household to finally get out in
the end Chris's friend, rod surmises the entire film in one offhand joke.
I may have told you not to go in the house, get out. And the purge, Mark,
a shift in how Blumhouse films present the home.
Whereas early Blumhouse films focused on how seemingly idealistic homes and
neighborhoods are no longer safe, corrupted by unseen monsters.
These later films present the home as symbiotic with the monster.
It's not that the Armitage family has corrupted in.
Otherwise the nice suburb they're evil is one in the same in Jordan peals,
follow up us,
the Wilsons and upwardly mobile black family take a trip to their summer home in
an upper-class beach side community. And yet again,
something doesn't feel right,
but this time it isn't that everyone else is out to get them it's themselves.
They have to worry about.
I can't be here. It's too much.
It feels like there's this some black
cloud.
It's not too soon thereafter that the family is attacked by their doppelgangers
resentful of their other halves, posh lifestyle.
Give it to her.
The message behind us boils down to what does the.
Dream of upward mobility of suburban bliss actually mean for everyone else who
gets to live in a house and conversely,
who doesn't the literal real estate occupied by the Wilson family.
And others means a cast of people who are relegated to living below ground.
Outside of that dream.
The basic question of the film posits are there casualties in our quest for the
American dream.
The idea that homes can twist us beyond recognition by Adelaide for getting,
she actually came from the underground is a recurrent theme in later Blumhouse
films in get out. If Chris stays with the Armitage's in their home,
he will forever live in the sunken place.
And then Blumhouse is the invisible man Cecilia confides that she had to escape
her home because she didn't feel like herself there under her abusive husband's
thumb. She was becoming a different version of herself.
He controlled how I looked and what I wore
and what I eat.
Similarly in Blumhouse is Halloween sequel.
Laurie's daughter comments that she had to get away from her mother and their
house less. She ended up just like her.
I've spent my entire life praying to get over the paranoia and
neuroses that she has projected.
Later when Laurie kills Michael Myers,
she does so not by expunging the boogeyman from the home,
but by trapping him inside the home now becomes a literal prison.
Just this year, Blumhouse released their latest film. You should have left,
which not.
So coincidentally it's about a family trapped in a house which refuses to let
them leave. Somehow Blumhouse has yet again,
tapped into the zeitgeists at a time when people are stuck self isolating in
their homes.
This new film reflects these same fears from the company's inception.
Blumhouse has pressingly reflected the current client, often spookily,
predicting what's to come listen to our new founding fathers.
And America, a nation reborn.
From the economic crisis of the early aughts to today's quarantined blues.
How has Blumhouse been so consistently on point,
it was just a result of their cheapo business model,
or if they made some frosty and deal with the devil themselves.
It has been said that if a human makes a bargain with a demon for wealth power
or any other benefit, they must forfeit their first born man.
Regardless, the result is the same Blumhouse has captured the American home,
like no other twisting the place, which we spend the most time into our undoing.
So wisecrack,
what do you think has Blumhouse made you afraid of your house or do you
foolishly still sleep soundly at night?
Let us know in the comments below huge thanks to our patrons for all your
support purge that subscribe button of all its demons and as always,
thanks for watching guys.
[Inaudible].